hello everybody how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing fine better than me
and it's uh quite a world out there
today anyways let me start again
my little sales pitch I've uploaded a
book the Rope hypothesis in it brings
you up to speed on what we talked about
in this channel which is the Rope
hypothesis proposing that all atoms in
the universe are interconnected okay and
if you have a second language native
language of some kind we would
appreciate if you contact us at toka
cockeyed hotmail calm and you know
propose that you can translate it to
your own native language and we'll send
you a file that you can modify anyways
uh yeah like I said quite a surrealistic
world out there I'm here in Germany in
Frankfurt and the province or the state
here is called Essen the other day about
four or five days ago economic Minister
of this state committed suicide and the
word around town is that he committed
suicide because he couldn't stand his
wife for two days okay a lot of jokes
that you hear out there they were full
of jokes on this thing so you don't know
how to treat it yeah it's quite so
realistic you know over here if you want
to take mean the only places that are
open are really the supermarkets right
and you go to a supermarket you get your
cart oh you used to put a coin in there
to be able to pull that card out and
take it inside the store well now all
these you know where you put the coin
it's it's all blocked with tape because
they only allow like twenty people
inside a store each store has a
different number of people that they
allow in there and so once you get the
twenty cards the other guy has to wait
in line for a car
otherwise he doesn't get in soon as you
go in they spray your hands and you know
the the car to make sure it's not
contaminated so I'm wondering you know a
lot of these things will continue
probably after this whole thing blows
over
how much of it will blow over I don't
know a lot of people staying at home and
getting things through internet like
Amazon like and I don't know if that's
gonna change I think a lot of people
will switch over to that they're gonna
be less window shopping you know window
shopping it's gonna be done online and
so I think there's going to be a lot of
habits a lot of behaviors that are gonna
change with this virus this is not so
much with the virus but with the what
the politicians have implemented as a
result of the virus right and so yeah
keep that in mind there is gonna be some
changes and I don't know if we're gonna
go back to normal okay and about talking
talking about you know going back to
normal that includes whether we're going
back to the economic system we used to
have you know there's a lot of people
that lost their jobs think there's like
three point two or three point three
million applications for unemployment in
the US alone and other countries are in
the same shape so there's a lot of
unemployment scuffie out there and i'm
not sure you're gonna recover that
unemployment overnight it's not like in
three months assuming just blows over
and a month and a half and then they
pick up things start picking up back
again I'm not sure we're gonna go back
to full unemployed employment overnight
it's gonna take a while and the question
is whether they can remember you're not
creating manufacturing or agricultural
jobs anymore now you're creating service
jobs nonsense jobs it's unemployment
jobs you know an aside from that there's
this help from the government giving
money to people giving money to
companies that so they
don't go under so they don't lay off
people that sort of thing and what that
does is create you know a lot of money
out there and that's gonna lower the
wages the salaries of people who you
know the proletarians people who want to
depend on their salaries so yeah it's
gonna be very interesting in the next
few months what's going what's gonna
happen and well a lot of you know my
theory I've been peddling it for twenty
years it's gonna be economics that's
kills us it's not going to be the
climate change that's nonsense
not that it's nonsense whether the
climate is changing that's not the issue
the issue it's got nothing to do with
extinction of the extinction of man it's
not going to cause the extinction of man
asteroids not gonna cause the extinction
of man you know disease itself the virus
not gonna cause the extinction of man no
no what's gonna cause the extinction of
man according to my theory is economics
man's artificial economic economics this
economic system we created this monster
we created this abstract monster we
created called money
I think that's gonna collapse and I
written a couple papers okay and here
you can see something about them now you
can look them up there in the
description okay you can find the link
there you can read them on
sustainability and we are the last
generation of humans on earth been
peddling that theory now for twenty
years and you know a lot of people don't
like the theory that a lot of people
don't believe it especially anywhere
from 20 to 40 year-olds they don't like
that theory and it's not a good in that
nice theory to here it's like you know
the doctor telling you that you got six
months to live who likes to hear that
you know it says a very unpopular theory
of people always seek a second opinion
now this you got to think about it you
know in your mind you got to crunch it
in there for yourself and figure out
whether it makes any sense to you now a
lot of people have criticized me and say
well bill your predictions have not come
and yeah I'm a lousy astrologer that
doesn't make me a lousy scientist
scientist deals with how an astrology
astrologer deals with when and you know
I have my own opinions and again I'm a
lousy astrologer about when it's gonna
happen and you should not throw the baby
or you know with the bathwater it's
simply because you know the prediction
didn't come true you know I had made a
lot of predictions over the years
regarding when it's gonna happen that
was my personal opinion you know but
that's got nothing to do with though a
theory which explains how what the
mechanism is and that's what you're
gonna find in the in the descriptions
there's two papers there that I
published one in 2010 the other one 2016
you're welcome to read them they're for
free okay okay what am I going to talk
about today I'm going to talk about a
little bit about geometry we were on
this subject now for a couple of weeks
and I'm gonna hard.you today that the
Greeks set us off on the wrong foot and
not only have they set us off on the
wrong foot but we landed on the wrong
foot today we don't have any valid
rational notions of geometry okay our
foundations are rotten to the core
that's what I'm gonna argue today but
see the issue of guide mentions okay so
I'm gonna get to that and I'm gonna pick
on a little fellow who died a couple
years ago his name was Stephen Hawking
and he was a relativist and you know he
made a lot of money selling his books
and his theories regarding relativity
four-dimensional spacetime zero
dimensional black holes it was all
dimensional and a lot of that comes
right back to geometry okay so yeah I'm
gonna look at geometry and then how it
affects the theories that we have out
there today okay okay so where do we
start well here we have this fellow and
his name
Plato and he had a sign on the door of
his Academy and in this is one person I
have seen several versions of this it
says look let no one destitute of
geometry enter my doors okay so Plato
said you know you gotta know geometry if
you want to be intelligent otherwise
you're ignoramus
okay now the big problem I've got with
geometry okay to begin with okay is that
in attempts it's the first step in
attempting to unite mathematics with
physics okay it's trying to apply
mathematics to physical issues now as
long as you applied math to measurements
and calculations that sort of thing
well yeah that's fine that stays within
the realm of mathematics those are just
descriptions it's when the
mathematicians take that extra step and
they say they now can interpret the
universe the workings of the universe
the invisible workings of the universe
you know gravity magnetism light
electricity those kinds of things when
they claim that they can interpret those
thanks to their mathematics now that's
when we get to voodoo magic and that's
why we have only irrational theories
today freshly out of quantum mechanics
and general relativity okay so that's
that's the point I'm going to try to
make today in general ok ok so where do
we start well here we have mr. Euclid he
was a guy who came one or two
generations after Aristotle no one knows
exactly when he was born when he died
all we have is his book elements
elements of geometry and all we can do
is you know find out from his book what
the notions that the Greeks had of
geometry which is the one that serves us
a foundations for what we have today ok
and again he came one or two generations
after Aristotle oh he very
likely studied not only at the Lyceum
that Aristotle had in Athens but
probably also at the Academy which you
know Plato had died but his students
continued and so this Academy was still
open so he probably studying both of
those more than likely and then he wrote
this book elements which kind of
synthesizes the notions that the Greeks
had of geometry you know about two
hundred three hundred years before
Christ okay and so here it is this is
the first problem I find with Euclid and
that's his point okay and again I'm not
gonna beat up on Euclid alone because he
got all this from his teachers which
means he just regurgitated what he
learned in college in those days that
was college right and he's got this know
part point meaning it's got no volume no
sighs no it's zero dimensional it's got
no dimensions and that's called the
point big problem I've got with that
that's not a geometric figure okay
there's no such figure that is zero
dimensional so we got a problem here
because he starts out with this no part
point which no one can define to this
day yay and it turns out it's not a
geometric figure because you cannot
imagine something something a thing that
is zero dimension zero volume zero size
okay there's no such notion okay
contradicts the definition of what a
figure is what an object is which is
shape okay so that's where the problem
is
that's where it starts so it's not a
figure and what they really use the
point for you know they don't claim it's
a figure at least that's not what it's
used for the word point is used to
represent a location and there you have
a X Y you know two coordinates that give
you a location and that's what the point
represents you know so the you know
these are pairs they also have triplets
and quadruplets and so on okay
and uh is that a couple numbers is that
what a geometric figure is okay so we
got a problem with what geometry intends
which is a study of shapes and to start
up with this building block which is
called the point which is 0 that mention
oh no volume no size no dimensions right
nothing and that's the building block
and they're gonna use that also remember
they're gonna use that in quantum
mechanics they're gonna use that in
general relativity so don't dismiss the
point as well very trivial no no it's
the building block of all of
mathematical physics that point so that
point is extremely important and you can
see it's misconceived from the start
because it's not even a geometric figure
okay so where do we go from there and
well we go to the line okay and here's
the line what's the problem with the
line the problem is first it's
one-dimensional and again there's no
figure no geometric figure that is
one-dimensional okay that's the first
problem what you see there the reason
you can see it it's two-dimensional that
thing that that red thing that you see
there has length I'm sorry it has width
and it has height that's two dimensions
at least otherwise you wouldn't be able
to see it and yeah there's no way you
can represent a one dimensional anything
unless you have up these two dimensions
you know scribbled with your pen or your
chalk or your crayon okay so that's the
issue so a line is not a figure not if
it's one-dimensional not if it's like
you could set breathless length if it's
just length and it has no other no other
dimensions it doesn't have width or
height then all you're talking about is
nothing yeah that's the problem
okay so we got a problem that and that's
the reason they can't define the word
what is it
line today they can't defined a point
they can't define the line why because
one of the issues is that a in objects
is that which has shape and you do not
define objects you point to them
that's what you do you point you point
to a table
you say look table then you can describe
it and say it's got four legs you know
take a board over it you know whatever
the point is that you point to things
you do you don't define them so all the
words in the dictionary that represent
objects you point to concepts you define
and what they're trying to do is define
objects that's why they have problems
also defining point line and plane as
we'll see okay so the other problem with
Euclid's line is that extends
incessantly forever and there's no
object no physical entity that extends
across the universe and beyond even
beyond God's heaven no such monster okay
all objects are finite and if you have
an infinite object then you're not
talking about an object because all
objects are finite an object is that
which has shape you should be able to
visualize it you should be able to draw
it whatever object is even if you're a
poor artist you know I'm a lousy artist
but I can draw a line I cannot draw an
infinite line and the line that I drew
is what they call a line segment not a
line because the line is infinite okay
so so we got a problem with that there's
no object called line that is infinite
okay that's the problem and and when we
get to that next poem you see why
because the line is not used as a
geometric figure a line is used to
represent distance displacement time and
number okay and we mean when we talk
about distance it's not really distance
they're not talking about separation
between two objects what they're talking
about is distance traveled which is no
different than this placement or motion
or whatever okay so that's what the line
is used for it's not used for
Elementary which is first and foremost
the study of shapes okay and yeah
they're gonna use that to make relations
between within objects and between
objects but that's different than saying
that the line itself is a geometric
figure okay so so we got a problem there
with a point and with a line does it
stop there
well no here we have another it's an
extension essentially or a corollary of
the line which is the parallel lines
okay and you could attempt it to define
these again it's the Greeks he just kind
of condensed all the information or all
the knowledge that the Greeks had about
these things okay there are there
notions and according to the Euclid you
know lines should meet at infinity okay
that shouldn't should not meet at
infinity in other if they do meet at
infinity then they are not parallel
lines well the problem is you know we
must go to infinity to prove whether the
lines are parallel or not and that's not
a definition that's a proof disguised as
a definition okay they say look you got
to run a test yeah go and run to the end
of infinity if you can find infinity or
if you if it has an end right and find
out if these two lines meet and you go
off and you never come back you know so
we don't know if the equal sign that we
use in mathematics is our parallel those
two lines are parallel because you know
those are line segments and here they're
talking about lines that extend forever
you got to find out if they meet at
infinity so again that's a proof this
guy's there's a definition it's what
they call an operational or functional
death the definition the true
definitions equidistant lines but what
is a operational functional definition
well here it is let's put it over here
okay people think this is that
operational and that these types of
definition operational and function of
our scientific now they're not an
operational definition just a
well-defined these are from the from
other people I haven't none of this is
mine I'm just giving you what I found on
the Internet okay an operational
definition is just a well defined
repeatable experimental procedure whose
result defines a word or works well
that's not how we do it in science we
don't we don't define words after
running an experiment we do it the other
way around we first run an experiment
and we first define and then run the
experiments so we know what we're doing
okay and that says an operational
definition requires an operation a
procedure a way of measuring the
variable of interest and so what have
they ended up with as far as operational
definition well here you have some
examples what is the numbers that appear
when that object is placed on a weighing
scale is that the definition of weight
no no wait has certainly you got it you
got to know what weight is before you
put anything on the scale operational
definition of intelligence I administer
the Stanford bla la la la i q-- test to
a person and score the result the
person's intelligence is the score on
the test great so so that's what it
comes down to that's what your
intelligence shows up as a number we
build operational definition for the
words particles and waves now you know
how they came up with particles and
waves in quantum mechanics there are
operational definitions they say look we
saw we didn't see something in there but
whatever it is it has these two
properties and we're just going to
define it on on that basis and then the
last one we explain what a carburetor is
in terms of how it interacts with
ignition chambers no no you got to tell
me what a what a carburetor is before
you do anything with it okay so yeah all
these definitions operational and
functional definitions they're not
scientific because in science we define
first and then use the word later you
can't use the word throughout your
dissertation and then say oh by the way
this is what I was talking about for the
last two hours
this is an operational functional
definition okay so what is a parallel
line again well then that's her that's
what it is okay it's equidistant lines
okay if they have the same distance
separation not distance traveled but
separation we're done and it's by
definition if they do have it we're done
yeah that's that's what we mean by
parallel so it's very straightforward in
physics you know what the word parallel
means Euclid's planes well here they are
his plane extended forever it was made
of lines and lies extend forever so do
his planes so what is an infinite
triangle look like is it very different
than an infinite square or a different
circle I mean you know when you say
infinite you lost everything you have no
shape and therefore you don't even know
if you have a figure what is that thing
that is so infinite okay and here you
see breath is a vector and so I don't
know if it was Euclid or the translator
who used the word breath but breath has
nothing to do with dimensions okay so he
was talking about dimensions here you
have a vector breath is a vector we'll
see that in a second here a plane is a
type of figure that is expanding yeah
again expands forever and again like the
line is infinite and again that's
because because of that it's that a
plane the planes the series of planes if
they're infinite and extend forever then
they have nothing to do with geometry
you're talking about something else
they're talking about some concepts that
have nothing to do with shape which is
the first first and foremost requirement
prerequisite to belong to geometry
okay so what is a plane well here I have
it put over here and it's a category of
rigid continuous smooth ideal geometric
figures that are two-dimensional that's
it a particular face or cross-section of
an ideal solid if you have a cylinder
the end of it is a circle if you have a
cube D you know one end of it is
they squared and so on down the line
that that's what it is it's the face of
a solid in general okay now I'm not sure
you can do that with every plane but
with at least the most important planes
you can yeah that's what uh that's what
a plane is yeah and then and then it
belongs to geometry okay okay where does
all this uh
find a brick wall well the notions that
the Greeks and that they have to take
run against the brick wall was here's a
good example is the circle okay here's
the definition of circle that all these
people came up with Euclid came and
Greeks came up and said a circle is a
plane figure contained by one line such
that all the straight lines falling upon
it form one point from one point among
those lying within the figure equal
another an equal one another okay and
you can see that on the lower left hand
corner that's Euclid's circle and the
problem there is that all these lines
they hit on a line that's going around
and the question is whether between any
two lines there's another line and if
they are they're all separate because
you know a line is different than
another line a neighboring line so
there's got to be space between them
that means it's not a continuous figure
the circle according to Euclid are we
doing any better with the modern version
well they say a circle is the set of
points in a plane that are equidistant
from a given point
that's wolfram who's got this in there
and the problem there is again the set
of points if each point is individual
each point is a separate distinct entity
from the one from the one next to it
then it's not a continuous figure by
definition so we got a problem with
these definitions because we're now
talking about a continuous plane we're
talking about
a segmented sort of figure no matter how
you look at it to make matters worse
they say look and you can see that in
the drawing next to Stephen Hawking
they're gonna rotate something around
let's see what it is and that's
Wikipedia says a circle is a shape
consisting of all points in a plane that
are a given distance from a given point
that's the same thing we had just now
but it says equivalently it is the curve
traced out by a point that moves in a
plane so that it's distance from a given
point is constant okay so you get the
relativistic circle there the one that
is used by mathematicians which is just
a bunch of dots bunch of points
surrounding a center okay there's
nothing between the dots on the outside
and the dot in the center there's
nothing there in other words what you're
talking about is a ring in which none of
the points are connected because all
those are discrete points so is this a
geometric figure is this a plane we talk
about a ring major that are not even
that where the dots are not even
connected because there's always a dot
between any two others so we got a
problem with those definitions because
they're not talking about a geometric
figure and to make matters worse the
definition from Wikipedia shows us this
it says look if you throw a point around
that's a circle well this is is that a
circle looks to me like an orbit not a
not a circle I mean you tell me okay so
what they do is they say well bill what
you're talking about is not a circle
you're talking about a disk okay you're
talking about a figure that is
continuous from edge to edge of that
circle circumference that's surrounding
it so let's look at this let's look at
these definitions that these people have
yeah and here it is okay it says the
difference between discs in circle hey
look at this because I always thought
the circle was a geometric figure now
they're say no no that's the disk the
circle something else okay let's look at
this the disk is a thin flat circular
plate or similar object with circle
while circle is to geometry absolutely
not a two dimension
geometric failure no it's not it's a
it's an itinerary or it's a series of
dots which are not connected to each
other they just have us the same
distance from a Sutton Center okay
that's not our geometric figure that's a
bunch of dots that's all it is because
there's nothing between the dot in the
center node on the edge a
two-dimensional geometric figure
absolutely 9 a line consisting of the
sets of all those points in a plane that
are equally distant from another point
no we don't even have a plane because if
we have a plane then you you must cut it
like if you if you're gonna make a plane
like for Show and Tell okay you can cut
all around the paper and you can say
look this is a circle that's that's a
plane but or a representation of a plane
but I can't bring to the conference a
bunch of points that are not even
connected I mean I can bring the best I
can bring is a caller you know with all
those pearls around it but even those
that I have to connect with a little
line so that people realize that it's
all connected so no the circle of
mathematics has nothing to do with
geometry okay and shows the problem with
their definition today now whether they
can use in mathematics irrelevant you
know they could keep it there I don't
care I just don't want them bringing
that nonsense it the physics that's
where the problem is that's what I'm
gonna talk about today
okay this call so this is the region in
a plane bounded by a circle yeah there
is no region because there's no matter
there no no no nothing between the the
circle within the circumference within
one edge and the other edge there's
nothing there
all they have is a distance they same
from the center point to the edge that's
all they have a distance there's nothing
there's there's no thing in there okay
that's what I want to make sure yeah
that you understand a disc is said to be
closed if it contains okay la la la
circumference what is the circumference
it looks like there is no difference
between circumference and circle then
right well they say circumference of a
circle is the
linear distance around it so so we got a
problem here because they say the
circles all those dots around that's so
called the geometric figure but if you
hop from point to point
all around okay and you measure that
distance well that's a circumference so
circumference has to do so-called with
more more with mathematics like we need
a number for circumference and and
circle is the thing that surrounds the
circle but this or whatever right so no
we got a problem with all these notions
that mathematics has come up with okay
and just to top it off what they do a
lot which is totally illegal okay
is this they have they have the circle
the square and the triangle and they
tilt them they twirl them around they
say oh we still have a square no we
don't because of all these things can
only be seen head-on as soon as you move
them in any way they lose their shape
and in fact if you put it straight you
know like if you turn it 90 degrees
completely so that the edge points at
your eyes had disappeared it should
disappear completely because a plane has
no thickness okay so we got a problem
with with all these people who start you
know moving these planes around you
can't move a plane because a plane can
only be seen straight on
you know head-on yeah so too many
problems with what geometry has today
foundations I'm talking about the
foundations okay you say well so what's
the problem with all this so who cares I
mean fine okay so so they screwed up
with some of the basics they don't have
the definitions you don't have a good
idea of what these geometric figures are
but they use them and they can do a lot
of stuff with it well again the big
problem here is when they introduce all
this stuff this mathematical nonsense
when they bring it into physics and they
say oh now I'm gonna do physics with all
this see that was the geometry was a
stepping stone into mathematical physics
and I are you here and I will argue till
my dying days mathematics has nothing to
do with physics and physics as nothing
to do with mathematics physics belongs
to science and physics we must explain
phenomena especially invisible for now
we need to explain magnetism gravity
that sort of thing
mathematics can only describe and the
attempt to unite these two and create
this religion called mathematical
physics is what took us into nonsense
such as black holes space-time big bang
traveling through time and all this
nonsense and so it is important because
this is the foundation what you're
seeing here this is where they're all
started started with a point with the
line with the Greeks that's where it
started and that's how it developed over
the last two thousand plus years ok so
here we have a an example and it's mr.
Stephen Hawking and he died a couple
years ago and you can see where the some
of the problems come in here you have
unit of length called a light second AHA
light second is that a length
I thought length was you know the length
of a table you know how long is a table
that's what length is these people
talking about something else they say
look I'm gonna time something with my
clock and time how long it take time it
takes for a beam of light for example to
go from here to there so we're talking
about two different things that's not a
length that's again it shows how these
people confuse length which is like the
length of a table with measuring
something with a clock which is distance
not even distance called distance travel
here I have a quick picture that shows
length is what a box has okay that's
length and distance is what's between
two boxes i synthesize distance is what
lies between lengths that's the correct
way of understanding distance and length
what these people are talking about
they're talking about distance traveled
they always talked about measure
they're unrolling the measuring tape
that's what both distance and length
mean to a mathematician and therefore
they've always introduced this distance
traveled as distance or his length and
in fact if you look up the words
distance and lank you'll find that
they're synonym perfect synonyms in
mathematical physics not so in physics
and in his book a brief history of time
hockey says defines this in his glossary
says a point in space-time so now that's
what an event is here you have an event
which is something that happened and
he's gonna use a point to represent it I
point is a static object I mean assuming
a head shape in turns eyes doesn't even
have shape but let's assume it has shape
it's a dot right are you gonna represent
a something that happened a movie with
the photograph are you gonna represent
an event with a dot makes no sense these
people are saying that an event is just
a point and they're gonna build
space-time with all these points all
these happenings that happen suppose the
end zero time because that's what a
point is point has nothing to do with
time where it where as event does and
you can see also that there's yeah a
little bit of a contradiction there
between field an elementary particle a
particle supposedly is a field a
vibrating field what is a what is it
that it's vibrating well it's a field
that's vibrating locally okay but when
you go to field it says something again
they never define something that exists
they never defined exists even though
they use these words every two seconds
right something that exists throughout
space and time in other words it field
covers all the space-time we're done we
don't have to identify it we don't have
to know what it is we just say it it
covers all of space-time so what is an
elementary particle well it's one that
cannot be subdivided and it's a party
and what is a particle particle is just
a vibration of the field locally and
what what does that mean as far as size
and so on one's got no sighs it's just
an infinitesimal part of a field so you
can see how they get away with all this
stuff because you know they are they are
manip
leading the language here it has nothing
to do with reality just has to do with
language with semantics that's what
they're doing okay so here's a good old
Stephen Hawking and he continues in his
book he says one could specify that
appointment was at a certain latitude
and longitude and a certain height above
sea level
one is free to use any three suitable
coordinates height is a coordinate
I thought height was a dimension I
thought we had length width and height
within mentions if I got it right I
don't know maybe I got a wrong you you
correct me right and you had latitude
longitude and altitude and those who are
coordinates and these people mix
coordinates dimensions they don't care
they mix them all together hey you saw
the word breadth which is a vector they
bring that in their depth breadth and
elevation they bring that all the same
to them and it's all the same because
they're not talking about dimensions
coordinates or vectors they're talking
about number lines that's the issue the
issues number lines okay and so we have
to educate them a little bit here's a
good chart that puts it at the right
perspective dimensions they have to do
with orientation and tilt that sort of
thing you have length width and height
straight forward babies can understand
this except mathematicians coordinates
they have to do with location and they
point inwards towards the object okay
longitude altitude and latitude they
come towards the object and vectors have
to do with motion they have nothing to
do with orientation location food I
mentions or coordinates they have to do
with the motion of an object in three
mutually perpendicular directions death
breath and elevation what the what are
the mathematicians talking about they're
talking about quantitative stuff they're
talking about number lines and number
lines have what dimensions coordinates
and vectors don't have and vice versa
these have properties or attributes
which number lines don't have a
dimension coordinate or vector has
two properties it's mutually
perpendicular to the other two and it's
got direction and number lines have
neither one of those two number lines
have magnitude and do not have direction
or perpendicularly to anything and so we
got a problem because these people are
using the words of physics that meant
for example length with a knight to talk
about number lines when the physical
notion of length width and height has
nothing to do with numbers and numbers
have nothing to do with dimensions and
that's how we get to four-dimensional
space-time so keep that in mind that's
how they came up with 4d space-time now
know it's for number lined space-time
they're not talking about that mentions
vectors or coordinates they're talking
about numbers okay which has nothing to
do with physics or with dimensions
coordinates vectors okay here's another
thing that you get out of Stephen
Hawking's book which is relevant to
dimensions it's easy to draw diagrams of
two dimensional spaces spaces whatever
that is okay such as the surface of the
earth the surface of the earth is
two-dimensional because the position of
a point can be specified by two
coordinates latitude and longitude well
I'm sorry to tell mr. Hawking but it
looks like he's a flat earther huh he's
uh he's talking about this I guess you
know he's saying in two that mentions
he's he's gonna have our two coordinates
a latitude and longitude he's talking
about this you say look you got the map
there right and you can locate any point
where the latitude and longitude you'd
only need these two coordinates well
yeah that's if you have an American tour
map you know I guess he's talking about
the flat universe flat the earth that he
probably believed in or confused it with
I don't know the earth has for his
information has a little more than two
coordinates it's got a third one okay
and did you forget about radius the
center of the
earth to that point there that he needs
on the surface of the earth yeah you
need three or he's taking it for granted
he's saying look we can go move around
the the earth no if you move around then
you're you're you're cheating because
you're treating the earth as a flat
surface you can't do that either this
the earth is rather that's why you know
we can't have it both ways so if you
only need two coordinates to locate a
point on the surface of the earth
you're a flat earther we're done okay
that's how simple it is so now you need
three but he takes the third one for
granted which is the actually the
altitude okay okay
what else does mr. Hawking say that kind
of you know is counterintuitive
okay and then he says the following the
solidus book by the way 1988 famous book
that made a lot of money with what I'm
gonna use a different set of three
coordinates okay to specify the position
of a point okay an event is something
that happens at a particular point in
space in a particular time so one can
specify it with four numbers or
coordinates uh-huh we need four numbers
or coordinates to specify a an event I
thought he said you just needed two
coordinates to located a point on the
surface of the earth now he's got two
more nice needs four okay again the
choice of coordinates is arbitrary one
can use any well define any three well
defined spatial coordinates and any
measure of time in relativity there is
no real distinction between the space
and time coordinates just as there is no
real difference between any two space
coordinates so you saying time is no
different than space as far as these
little engine arrows that he draws
they're all the same to him why because
they're all number lines that's why I
mean qualitatively you know hopefully
height and width and length a little
qualitatively different than time the
others are us you know static they don't
move you just point say length width
height
we're done and time is something that
rolls along to infinity properly who
knows I'm here as long as we live
forever you're gonna have comparisons of
two motions which is the definition of
time and so time runs runs period we
don't have to say forever or anything
like that we just have to say time runs
whereas length width and height they
don't run they don't move at all they're
static static concepts so to say that
there's no difference and means you're
talking about math not physics okay
again it's the attempt to introduce
these notions into physics that is
offensive okay and he illustrates this
time dimension and he talks about here
it is okay he says I shall generally use
diagrams in which time increases upward
and one of the spatial dimensions is
shown horizontally okay he's got two
dimensions they're horizontally he calls
them space I don't know of any dimension
called space I know what one called
with the other one called length another
one called height and he replaced the
height one with time the other two
spatial dimensions are ignored oh okay
yeah he couldn't fit them in there so he
ignores them he says let's get rid of
them we don't need them and these are
called space-time diagrams well yeah yes
you know if he says so you know yeah
what does this have to do with physics
this might be useful in mathematics I
don't know maybe it's good for them but
it's got nothing to do with physics okay
and here you can see a little bit of why
here's the coordinate system as you know
what a coordinate system is especially
the famous Cartesian you know Descartes
Cartesian coordinate system a coordinate
system is a system that uses one or more
numbers what is the coordinate it's a
number does that have anything to do
with physics absolutely not okay so so
we got a problem because these people
are saying they're coordinates just a
number and that's on what a coordinate
is for the purposes of physics physics
it has to do with locating an object so
that's why you have latitude out
and longitude okay because they locate
an object all we want is qualitative
location that's all we're interested in
but here these people are using numbers
they say they're gonna measure something
I guess or coordinates to uniquely
determine the position of the points or
other geometric elements on a manifold
such as Euclidean space in other words
what they're doing is they're taking
measurements in they're calling these
measurements number lines they're
calling them dimensions or the condom
coordinates are they calling them
vectors that's the problem and there you
see well from a set of variables also
for the word coordinate right each set
of variables which fix a geometric
object in other words fixed the location
I guess that's what they're trying to
say there if the coordinates are
distance is measured along perpendicular
axis they are known as Cartesian
coordinates again what are we talking
about well we're talking about again
measuring and we're talking about
numbers we're not talking about physics
okay but this is what they're gonna use
and remember they're gonna use this for
determining space-time black holes or
itself that's based on all this nonsense
on these these notions okay so yeah they
have all these weird notions that they
created math they simply extrapolated
them into physics saying oh we're
mathematical physicists we're not just
geometers or mathematicians we have
something to do a physical bit the world
for you okay okay here's another notion
that Hawking has it is often helpful to
think of a four coordinate of the four
coordinates of an event as specifying
its position in a four dimensional space
called space-time it is impossible to
imagine a four-dimensional space no
kidding I wonder why why is it
impossible to imagine I mean Jesus I
mean if you can if you can do it with
math and math represents the physical
real world out there oh I don't see what
the problem is we should be able to take
all these numbers these but guess that's
what a coordinate is right that's what a
dimension is just a bunch of numbers
right
be able to take these numbers and
visualize the real world because they
say these numbers represent the real
world
and they can put a bunch of number
thinking put five numbers say it's five
dimensional and you go out there you
don't see these numbers all you see is
length width and height which is three
perpendicular directions now if you can
think of a fourth or a fifth
perpendicular direction it's because you
had too much beer to drink okay or you
were hit by the virus or something you
know yeah we got a problem with all
these notions okay they have nothing to
do with with with science or with
physics okay here's uh what he's
referring to when he's talking about
four-dimensional space-time okay when
you look it up you know what is this
space-time thingy that they're talking
about well here you see it okay this is
what you get when you look up the words
space-time you get all these fishnets
and spider webs
what are those specially what's the
background that sir what serves as
background to the fishnet because of the
fishnet is space-time what is the black
stuff that serves as or the white stuff
in the case of the one on the lower lung
was a background that's what we need to
identify I mean we have space-time and
what is the other one love is that is
that what it is okay so we've got a
problem with their conceptualization I
should be able to conceptualize it on
the board before they can make claims of
this nature okay here's a one famous
four dimensional object which they use
constantly to simulate space hammer to
show you that it is possible to imagine
or to conceptualize visualize you know
space-time because you start with the
hypercube okay here it is is that what
space-time is yeah what would we staring
at well what is this not to all I see is
a three-dimensional watch me call it
that is superimpose or projected onto a
two-dimensional platform or background I
don't see anything four dimensional in
that whole picture okay
and so let's find out what
this space-time or tesseract or
hypercube or hyper sphere for that
matter what what are these things let's
find out yeah and here it is Dan here
you can see what they really mean by
this they construct their figures and
what it is is a cube that is expanding
through time okay so we're talking about
a cube expanding and what they do they
take a photo of this movie called an
expanding cube and so they have what
they ended up with is with nested cubes
one cube inside another that's what it
is and the only question you should ask
yourself is what are those lines that
connect the vertices in other words what
are those slanted lines that go from one
corner of one cube to the corner of
another Q that's what we want to know
and what that is is time okay what you
have is an a cube that's expanding and
that those 45 degree lines those are
that's time okay so it doesn't stop
there then you they go through the other
step when they start 'men xed graph on
the bottom on the right that chart you
see that the queue expands horizontally
but then they take all these pictures of
movies and they make another movie out
of those movies and we have a movie of
movies because they start moving the
tesseract around as if they're moving an
object wonder what they're really doing
is moving time itself and and here you
have a little picture of that okay okay
here it is see what you're staring at is
two nested queues one smaller inside
another one the slanted lines that
connect the vertices those are that's
time because the little cube is actually
expanding forming the big cube and when
that finishes only can you move the cube
to the next position or a location and
so what you have is a movie of movies
that's which what a tesseract in a
rotating tassa rack
is or hypercube okay so this is what
they've come up with with all their
dimensional analysis on this
poppycock yeah mathematical physics has
invented it's not you can't even
conceptualize or visualize because once
you understand what they're putting in
front of you then you know it's bunk
it's all nonsense it's poppycock and
they said well you got to take the
course in university to understand it
yeah I guess you do you need that
brainwashing you know to really
understand it right okay so what are the
main points today let me just summarize
here okay and see if we can run through
them
so you take something home with you the
Greeks set geometry on the wrong path on
the wrong foot okay and we ended up on
the wrong path because we haven't made
any progress since the Greeks all we did
is twiddle around a little bit with the
definitions but these people never
figured out is you cannot define
geometric figures you point to them yeah
you have to point to a geometric figure
Circle Circle cube cube point if if it's
a dot yeah I can put two a dot I can't
point a zero-dimensional
no part point okay zero the point is not
a figure sure Wendy line is not a fit
you're either it represents motion the
other one another the point represents
location location is not a geometric
figure motion is not a geometric figure
so to say that you're going to use the
line to represent motion displacement
distance whatever you want to call it
whatever or time you know you're not
representing a physical object you're
not representing a geometric figure
you're using a geometric figure which is
not 1d it's 2d because that's what
you're gonna put in there you got to see
it it's got to be at least 2d what are
you using it for you're using it to
represent pictorially a concept it's I
using the heart to represent love say
here's here's love no no that's a heart
that's not love and that's what they're
doing there say here's here's a time no
no that's not time that's a line and
that line is two-dimensional it's a
plane it's not a one-dimensional
anything that's the problem
so we got a lot of contradictions got a
lot to do with language and failure to
define so if you wonder why I point line
have not been defined to this day now
you know why because you don't you don't
define a triangle you point to it okay
you can define the word plain yeah as a
category about figures that's okay
same with lines and with godly with the
point if you can you find it as a
category but that's not what they're
doing they're saying look the point is
that dot that I put on the board well
that's two dimension well now it's a
pictorial representation of a point Oh
what's the point that's a location
that's that's the problem it's a
circular argument
okay okay no object is zero the year 1d
okay parallel lines are equidistant yeah
that's what it is you don't you prove
that two lines are parallel by going to
infinity because you'll never come back
you'll never prove it okay so this is
nonsense
no no it's equidistant lines they have
the same distance and by distance I
don't mean distance traveled need
there's no measurement involved all you
say is they have the same separation by
definition okay and no such thing is an
infinite plane which is you know made of
infinite lines you know or lines that
extend infinitely right location
position is not a set of numbers okay
you don't say that the location of
something is is a number or two numbers
or an ordered pair or a triplet or
whatever no that's not a that's not a
that's not a location location is is a
qualitative concept okay and you just
have to have separation okay from
something then you have location with
respect to a house a tree or rock
whatever okay okay no object is 4d
because it's unimaginable and that's why
you know this nonsense about extra
dimensions beyond the three that we our
experience tells us it they're selling
you you know snake oil you drink a lot
of kool-aid there right time is not a
dimension it's a number line okay
math has no use for dimensions
coordinates or vectors the qualitative
notions we have in physics that's why
they dismiss that is well that's baby
stuff
yeah that's what we use in physics the
baby stuff what do they say what do they
use they use number lines which they
call dimensions coordinates and vectors
but ask them to label and tell you what
is the name of each one of their four or
five 626 dimensions what is the name of
them and what are you going to the
length with the night what are you going
to say next for dimension for example
they don't have a name for it because
you know I guess they ran out of names
there's no such monster okay these
people are talking about stuff they have
in their head not something that's out
there in reality keep that in mind okay
okay math only has used for number lines
no such thing as a 4d space-time okay
space-time is a concept so you can't say
that you live within a concept called
space-time no no all we have is atoms in
the universe which are have distance and
location separation and location with
respect to each other that's all we have
that's what is out there that's reality
anything beyond that it means you'd be
brainwashed you need to see a
psychiatrist okay 40 state space-time is
a 3d object in motion that's what
they're talking about as you saw with a
tesseract ok hypercube is a movie of
time in motion they don't even realize
this that one of the legs of the
hypercube is time and they have time why
because this cube is growing when they
turned that around they're moving time
around that's what they're doing you you
might say bill you're crazy no no that's
what they're doing believe me look it up
find out what those lines are they're
time that cube is expanding the fourth
dimension is time ok so you have length
through the night that's the Q where
does the time come in well that's in the
growing ok so they have this cube that's
growing and that's time and now they
trill that around they've got a movie of
this thing going up once it finishes
growing up not
well that's growing but once it finishes
it you got your first cube that's your
first frame of your next film which is
made out of all these nested cubes
that's what you're staring at when
you're seeing the tests or a core
hypercube rolled so it's all nonsense
anyways I'm gonna continue along this
line on what's next Sunday we'll see you
on Sunday and I hope you have some food
for thought
bye bye